[Music]
my biggest pet peeve is people who shoot
starfish Starkist tuna can back like
it's a jello shot like put that can away
your breakfast on fire that is the
biggest pet peeve it can just open and
eat in action
no I got that from there you toss but
it's true though you can just slam it
that I guess it's tequila shot life why
are you slumming that back like that
that's not good for your stomach and
then these are bad smell get to love tax
nerd fan
oh gosh people posting their feet on
Instagram probably nobody wants to see
that oh there's some multiple ones but
my biggest Pepe was probably silly to
Moses the toilet paper like I it has to
go over on top the fact that goes under
underneath like grosses me the [ __ ] out
excuse my language hopefully you can
believe that there's very very arid
setting hmm when people like I say
Spanish so they're like I'm sorry you
Mexican no offense like doing this or
anything but but I'm like there's so
many other people I see other you know
like from Chile or Spain or you know
other places uh anything that would be
one of my biggest pet peeves I hate
people arrive down in dirty cars have a
nice car to always be dirty people not
laughing at my jokes it's just annoying
when I'm sweating and people start to
touch me you know and these [ __ ]
annoys me I always say like don't touch
me please I'm sweating my biggest pet
peeve is when I'm riding in the car at
my mom and she's trying to sing along to
the radio but she doesn't know the words
so she's always like I have a second
when people are walking their dogs and
they let them
[Music]
long lines just fix I really hate it I
really annoys me that when people like
lick their fingers and then like
eat food like sharing food
pretty nasty bad tippers going to a
restaurant and you got tip your
bartender you knocked up your server
properly that is my biggest pet peeve
instantly on a first date cut off
probably spitting in a water fountain
well I really allowed people at my
school like
I don't know just like I'll go to school
in the morning and people will just be
yelling for no reason they'll be talking
to the friend like this close Wow I
don't yeah that's annoying people people
not using their blinkers guys me crazy
bad drivers biggest pet peeve I ride a
motorcycle to work every single day
absolute fat beef is bad drivers had
people for all I mean when people act a
title but I would say
I don't really believe that any one
person should really feel like they're
better than others I would also say I'm
we're like I did mine
but people smacking their lips when they
eat which I'm sometimes culprit of but
it's really annoying when people have
big nose hairs coming out of their nose
and my ear hairs coming out of their
ears I don't know why it bothers me so
much bad surgeons
have you had experiences oh no I am a
surgeon
Hey
my biggest pet peeve will have to be
chapped lips bad spelling I guess it
might be people who
who tend to be listening and they're not
so you realize that they're not really
listening to you at all you know and I
guess that would be a stupidity
Hey
[Music]
my biggest pet peeve
honestly like is a female with attitude
problem because know a dozen problems
[Music]
never atlast out on somebody into this
consider in approaching right
you approach somebody
the right way you should be
the right way with the sandwich but when
people undermine me that's some big
especially
when people are prejudiced about other
people
because they don't know other people's
experiences
think about what you say before you say
that really it really bothers me when
people just like you know
like jump to conclusions we like an
answer to a question like mainly with
like things like
like issues today as far as like gay or
stuff like that I'm not but
like you know I got cousins and stuff
who are you know they feel offended so
[Music]
that's a big issue for me like it's okay
to feel how you feel about it but I feel
like if it's negative just hold it in be
mindful that people have feelings so